c'est ici sur celle que jacques cartier
surnommait l'isle de bacchus que louise
bédard et guetteur demers ont choisi de
se lancer en 2011 dans l' aventure de la
viticulture guettant rêvait depuis
longtemps d'acheter une terre un
tracteur et de démarrer un vignoble le
vignoble et n'en avait pas parlé à sa
femme et ont livré dix mille vies moi
j'étais certain que le camionneur avait
fait une erreur mais non c'est chez nous
c'est mon mari qui avait commandé 10
villes
j'étais bon courage madame cajole les
vignes presque sept jours sur sept 7
mois par année et ce même si elle ne
boit pas une goutte de vin parce qu'elle
n'aime pas l'alcool
monsieur lui est en charge de la
construction du domaine et de
l'élaboration des vins et sont
accompagnés par le neurologue richard
bastien
je suis un un défenseur des vins
effervescents québec
donc quand ils m'ont approché pour ce
projet là j'ai tout de suite été emballé
motiver des vins bio effervescence au
l'île d'orléans avec un terroir pour moi
c'était super la seigneurie de l'irec
cultive si ces pages dans le pinot
meunier
c'est le seul domaine je vous le
confirme au québec avoir du pinot
meunier
ce cépage là qu'on retrouve
effectivement en champagne apporte
généralement à côté très charnue très
fruité dans les effervescents parmi les
quatre vingts mise en marché il y à un
mois
il ya justement le nuage effervescents
assemblée comme un champagne
il a d'ailleurs été servi aux conjoints
et conjointes des chefs d'état lors d'un
souper en marge du sommet du g7 à peine
quatre semaines après l'arrivée de leur
vin sur le marché ils en ont vendu plus
de la moitié à ce rythme ils seront en
rupture de stock avant la fin de l'année
parce qu'on vient d'acheter sidle
janvier pour recharger mes passagers on
connaissait pas vignerons donné au plus
au monde vigneron ici marie maude
banderille à radio canada
cette famille de l'île d'orléans